let me pull this story we got from the
daily mail
austrian clinic that ships abortion
pills to the u.s claims it has received
thousands of calls from women especially
in southern states wanting to stock up
on the drug after scotus's roe v wade
ruling was leaked
you know what's crazy about this
in the bill the democrats tried to pass
it says there can be no restrictions on
abortion via telemedicine
tell them i was like how do you do
abortion over the phone they prescribe
pills
to terminate the pregnancy i wonder
what's going to happen seriously with
the illegal distribution of abortion
pills i mean people are going to do it
women are going to they're doing it now
already is the government going to send
out you know state troopers or federal
police to go and arrest these women for
ordering stuff are abortion pills going
to be treated like like crack cocaine or
something yeah it's a good question i'm
not sure what the exact surrounding
legislation is going to be i know
according to some figures i've seen
there was as much as a 60 decline in the
rate of abortions in texas so we know
that restrictions will prevent them from
occurring in some number of instances
and they are pretty effective but of
course there are going to be some people
who find a way around the law yeah of
those what do we say 60 reduction that's
what i saw those are the numbers a lot
of those just might be unreported
abortions happening now that aren't
being reported or that they go to a
neighboring state numerically it can be
tricky let's uh agree let's let's have
the um
feminist triggering conversation should
men be allowed to abort their father
their paternal uh
responsibilities in a world in which
there's unfettered abortion
so let me let me phrase obviously i
think the more conservative people would
say no fathers should not abandon their
kids under the pretext that women
do let's say the law is passed
abortion up to nine months is legal
would you also need to codify that men
could be like i hereby abort my
responsibility
i mean lydia as a woman yeah
i'm not entirely sure about that i was
just thinking about that that is an
interesting question i do think that if
a mother has the right
so-called from the emanations and pin
numbers of the constitution
to execute their poor unborn child that
a father should definitely have some say
in whether he has to support a baby i
don't know the idea is if it's like my
body my choice and it's like
okay
if you then choose to have a baby
and you could choose not to which means
killing the baby then it is much less
morally ambiguous for a father to say i
choose not to have a baby because he's
not killing at that point well i think
what's absolutely true about this is
when something like abortion is
legalized and normalized you do see a
breakdown of the family so if a woman
does not have the obligation to care for
her own unborn child what obligation
does a man have to care for his child
and
i think that there's a sort of
consistency there but then i would also
say that it's a consistency towards the
direction of evil and two wrongs don't
make a right ultimately if fathers were
able to abandon their children after
they impregnated a woman without there
being any potential ramification or any
way for her to sue for child support we
would probably see even more abortions
but how how many progressive or liberal
women do you think would advocate for
men having the right to say i have
nothing to do with this baby hmm
that's a good question many yeah well
they would want the child support they
would say you owe me money well and
that's why it's so funny when liberals
are you know this past week have been
saying well well then if you're going to
force them to have have kids and then
the father has to be just as involved
and all the conservatives are saying yes
absolutely i know it's just arguing
again it just shows just how kind of
we're and obviously it's not just
limited to abortion it happens with
every single topic but the people just
talk past each other and they don't
really know what the other side well i
actually want i i i it is the rule
it is a tendency of the right to not
know the left's argument but the rule is
they typically they should say they
typically do and it is the rule on the
left they don't know the rights argument
that's why the left there's this meme
going around where it's like it's for us
a four panel comic where someone says my
religion says i can't do this and the
person says good for you then the person
says my religion says you can't do this
and they say f off and i'm like you
realize that means no gay marriage in
churches and no abortions at religious
hospitals because if you're saying okay
to someone who says my religion says i
can't do this no cakes for you no no
bait no no gay message cakes no trans
cakes
no abortions at religious hospitals and
no marriages at churches that say no
they clearly don't agree with that they
don't even know their own arguments no
they literally don't you know whatever
well also the thing that i love about
this is all of these hot takes about how
men should have to take care of their
children if they get a woman pregnant
they'll tweet something like well if
abortion isn't legal then
a man who gets a woman pregnant has a
responsibility to stay with her and care
for the child like it sounds like
something me disguised as a liberal
would say like hey guys you know what i
think i i think these men should have an
obligation to take care of the child
that they make they're like yeah that's
just marriage
exactly i i think if if the man gets her
pregnant then he should swear an oath
till death do them part and you know
what i think he should financially
provide for her and she should have the
opportunity to stay home and raise that
child i think she should be at home
raising that child if
if conservatives want to ban abortion
then we have to have traditional
marriages
oh no anything but that your terms are
acceptable and they're arguing on your
behalf for the next step of your
argument
that's why it's like guys these the the
pro-choice side which is to i mean like
the literal traditional liberal types
are sitting there confused like
shrugging
uh they're left out of this and the
overt pro-abortion side which is like
late term
terminate the baby whatever
they don't even know what they're
arguing against they're so far left they
can't see where the right is so they've
looped back and said traditional
marriage must be enforced if you take
away our rights so there's this idea
called horseshoe theory i've coined the
term i call this merry-go-round theory i
mean eventually they just go so far to
the left that they get to the right but
then they keep going back round to the
left it's not like they stay at a
reasonable position someone in the chat
actually said sheamus three rights make
a left
[Laughter]
it's kind of remarkable how the left has
gone so far left they've become racial
identitarians
where they're actually just like now
advocating for segregation and they've
begun advocating for traditional
marriage as a point against
conservatives who want it's like we'll
show you going around again
merry-go-round theory when i thought i
think the center stays there just like
watching it happen like
the biggest part well the biggest part
of the question is do you want the
babies to be able to be killed or not
maybe for certain people but i think
it's do you want the government involved
in these decisions and yes if the i've
always thought child support made sense
like if a dad if a guy goes out and gets
five women pregnant and then he just
goes off to santa barbara and to live on
the beach and smoke pot like he has you
know he did some he's created like he
has to follow through with what he's
done if women have the right to
terminate the pregnancy and the man says
i'm out then they have a choice to say
okay me too
so this is this is the point yeah
explain that a little bit i'm not i
don't quite understand if women have the
absolute right to end a pregnancy
because it's their body then there is no
legal argument for the man having any
responsibility at all
the woman gets pregnant she says this is
your fault you got me pregnant he says
you can always choose to get rid of it
have a nice day and leave we'd have a
lot of unmarried pregnancies and and i
gotta be honest i think the left would
actually be okay with that i think in
the long run yeah they would adopt that
position because ultimately they'll
support anything that denigrates the
family or familial responsibility but
there was a meme that said the reason
they won't accept that position is
because it takes power away from the
woman if the woman gets pregnant she
gets to choose whether or not the man is
is going to provide her or not
right so with marriage you have two
people who have to make an agreement
with the current laws
the woman can choose to terminate the
baby or keep it and the man has no
choice whatsoever
so pro-choice people are not pro-choice
they're
pro-half
they're pro-abortion they're pro-voting
if they were pro-choice it would involve
the man's right to choose whether or not
he wants to be a part of her family well
i i just see it as because when i was
covering the the pro-abortion protest
outside uh alito's home earlier this
week i was calling them that they were
they were pro-abortion protesters are at
this house and people are some people
were just saying oh you're being so
disingenuous by calling them
pro-abortion they're pro-choice and it's
the choice to do what yeah
it's like when the people are like the
civil war wasn't about slavery
right states rights to what exactly
exactly and so i mean i just view it as
that's that's what they're advocating i
mean that's the whole they're not
well let's let's
make one point real quick no this whole
okay all right well then no no no no no
no no
this whole point you just made here
where they would claim it was
disingenuous for you to call them
pro-abortion instead of pro-choice that
logic can be extended to literally any
political position i'm not pro-gun i'm
just pro for a person choosing to have a
gun you have to call gun rights
advocates pro-choice now you can't call
us pro-gun you have to call it
pro-choice i'm pro-choice on guns yeah
exactly have a right to choose and i
have no problem saying i'm pro-gun
exactly why won't they say pro-abortion
because they know it's evil we had in
the temcas newsroom
some articles that were like saying
pro-life pro-abortion anti-abortion
pro-choice anti-choice whatever um i
don't know who's ever said anti-choice
but i was just like i saw i saw a few
articles and i thought to myself we
shouldn't use pro-life or pro-choice
those are political terms we should we
should we should just refer to the
groups and what they advocate for in
that time
so when the left goes out like we are
proud choice and i'm like no you're
pro-abortion because i could name a
million circumstances where you don't
have you don't care about a person's
right to choose anything right vaccine
mandates is very obvious and they say
yeah well pro-lifers aren't pro-life
because they're for the death penalty
and i'm like yeah we're going to call
them anti-abortion if you're at a
protest and you're like abortion should
not be allowed you are an anti-abortion
protester saying pro-life is a political
term and i'm not going to make an
argument about what life means or what
choice means if you go out you say we
want abortion you're pro-abortion if you
say no abortion you're anti-abortion
we're done that's it yeah well it's
funny because they will usually try to
use terms like anti-abortion as a smear
as if it's something to be ashamed of
that i'm against abortion oh no also
they'll also use terms like pro-birth
like you're not pro-life you're just
pro-birth i'm like yes you maniac what
is wrong with being pro-birth like
because they don't know what your
argument is yeah and so they say like i
just when i see all these memes on
facebook i'm like it's so frustrating
because they've never talked to a
conservative about this and then so i
can see this and i can i'll say
something like
they'll say something ridiculous like
it's about power and old white men and
then i'll say something like actually
the majori the majority of uh pro-life
people tend to be
female that's right and it's actually
really simple because there's slightly
more women in this country you can call
whatever you want and then they'll say
you're a right winger and i'm like i'm
just trying to like tell you what
they're saying because you're not
talking to them yeah but they don't they
know when it comes to pro-choice i think
the reason that we're going to use
because some people will say i don't
want an abortion i'm not going to get
one but i don't think the government has
a right to stop other people from
deciding that stuff
does that but yeah
what if you have a five-year-old and you
and you lose your job and you can't
afford it anymore
are you
pro-choice
what depends on how you feel should the
government be involved in whether or not
you strangle your kid to death because
you're broke and can't afford the kid
question what if you have a
nine-month-old baby like it's been out
of the room for a gestation for nine
months nine months in fresh air and then
one day you're like i have no money
should you have a right to choose oh i
think that when you say pro-life it's
implicit that it's invol only when
you're talking about the abortion
conversation as well that's why i said
we won't use either in the context of
these protests teamcast.com won't say a
pro-life protester or a pro-choice we'll
say anti-abortion or pro-abortion
someone who shows up and says i'm
pro-life it's like it's a political term
but and there are many areas of life you
are not saying all life is sacred i
would say like if i'm pro-choice and i
but i don't think the government should
get involved but i'd be happier if no
one ever got an abortion that i'm not
pro-abortion i think abortion's horrific
you're not pro-choice
well i don't want the government to be
like you can't decide what to do with
your body so can i ask you so if you're
someone who is in favor of the second
amendment and strong gun rights but you
didn't personally own the gun would we
not still call you pro-gun
we wouldn't just say well he's
pro-choice he's pro-allowing to choose
you know allow someone to choose whether
they're going to own a gun we don't do
this yeah we don't do this with any
other political conversation
choice yeah well it's a second-tier
conversation it's a second-tier label
already you want to know what topic is
already there you want to know why they
call themselves pro-choice because it
sounds better than pro-abortion
absolutely yeah because abortion is like
the actual procedures and also a lot of
people don't want to get abortions that
feel like the government shouldn't be
involved in this pro-life sounds better
than anti-abortion granted pro-choice in
my opinion sounds worse
like pro-abortion sounds worse than than
anti-abortion sounds but these are
political terms meant to garner support
i i look at it this way what does it
mean to be pro-life in a general sense i
do not believe it encompasses all life
i certainly think there's an argument
from conservatives about some people
through due process forfeiting their
right to life the death penalty i can
understand that but i don't think that
is part of the conversation so i don't
like the term pro-life it's a broad
generalization life's an abuse
anti-abortion is fine you oppose
abortion shamus are you anti-abortion
yeah i am and i'm like i'm fine with
anti-abortion as a label but i still
think pro-life is consistent because my
desire to be anti-abortion it comes from
an understanding that all human life is
precious and sacred so i'm just very
proud of human life and so my issue is
the the conversation around the death
penalty is not a part of the pro or
anti-abortion argument so if there are
protesters outside saying abortion
should be banned i'm not going to be
like interesting the signs they're
holding up send a strong message about
the death penalty because it doesn't you
don't know their position on the death
penalty based on them saying they're
they're opposing abortion that's why i'm
like we
if if there was a protest for against
the death penalty we'd say pro and
anti-death penalty well yeah exactly so
the pro-life only is in the reference of
abortion is what that means and
pro-choice is only in the reference of
abortion nobody says
no no leftist goes to an anti-death
penalty protest holding up pro-life
science right if you were to talk about
the fair if if that language not art was
not already being used in the abortion
debate they probably would well yeah
maybe in the context that i've seen is
that because i've been covering the
southern border crisis a lot especially
since the last time i was on here um no
no one who who
you know advocates for what the
biomedications are doing which is
essentially opening up the southern
border to illegal immigration they're
not going to say they're pro open
borders they're going to say they're pro
immigrant they're you know they're pro
asylum seekers even though you know
when you break that down into well who's
who's crossing and how are they crossing
what are they doing after they illegally
cross an international border it gets
into the these word games i will say
though i am pro breakfast burrito
i think we can all agree on that how
many
how many uh what percentage of pro pro
life individuals conservatives do you
think would take issue with being told
they were anti-abortion and having that
label on them that's a good question i
don't think anyone who's against
abortion would be upset being called
anti-abortion and i can't i can't be
wrong i don't know how can i speak for
everyone i can tell you outright that
when i say pro-abortion they lose their
minds mm-hmm they say no way or not well
that was that that's exactly what i've
been experiencing the these these past
few weeks on you know random random
twitter this is what david pakman
tweeted and says where are the
pro-abortion people
and then you know hassan made a joke and
he was like me i'm trying to do this and
then i screen grabbed it and he accused
me of not understanding it was a joke
and i was like i thought it was funny
actually like because other people took
it seriously yeah it wasn't music i just
screen grabbed it and then he accused me
of taking it seriously but
david's own followers took it seriously
but the point is
when they say who's who are these
pro-abortion people they all go not
we're not pro-abortion we're just saying
it should be allowed it's like i i'm not
i'm not for drugs i'm just saying
everyone should be allowed to have well
but part of what was part of what was
particularly hilarious about that thread
that with uh pacman was it wasn't just
um you know hassan responding to it
there were many many people in the
replies getting a lot of likes saying
things like well of course i'm
pro-abortion just like i'm pro any other
medical procedure what's wrong with
abortion just completely destroying his
argument or the people saying there are
too many people in the world dying why
are you having kids anyway all right
settle down bill gates yeah yeah wow
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you